we're clowns we're clowns we're
ridiculous clowns you know I used to
open for myself as a character until
literally Theo told me he goes you're
doing too
much he's like you don't have an opener
I was like no I I open as a character
that a lot of my fans know and I would
do 20 minutes as someone else and then
new people would come to the show would
be like man that opener was
crazy people didn't know it was me yes I
used to open as somebody else for myself
that's unhinged and then I was like oh
you can just you're like are you our
Martin yes I think I am I think I am and
then I finally was like I'm just going
to have an opener I'm I'm going to bring
some people on the r yeah yeah yeah
maybe you don't have to do the quick
change the quick change out of a wig
into a glitter suit I was doing all this
with we didn't really know each other
that well on Chelsea Lately I never
worked on Chelsea Lately I just I worked
at Soul cycle remember I gave you my
business card and I Hest opposed to the
soulless cycle of comedy shows and
everybody would come in there I would
ask for a job
cuz like even before I knew you I felt
like I knew you yeah I also have that
very familiar face where people are like
I just know her it's because I used to
wait on you all the time I was the first
line of defense at Soul cycle so you
would come in be like hey and I'm like
hey whit got you here's my business card
and you would not pay attention every
day that you came into exercise it's
because you were on this endorphin high
I would be like here's a water here's a
towel I was the one who waited on you
every time you I come and I would like
buy a candle and leave every time and
then I would put my business card slide
it in the CLE I wouldn't even put him at
the bottom of the bag I'd slide it in
where the candle was cuz I thought you
would open it and then I realized you
were probably just giving them his gifts
so all of your other friends to people
it was like 20 candles later that I was
like everybody else that's in Whitney's
life is getting my business card it's
not Whitney because had I known I would
have been like this is a Money Train
yeah I just thought because I adored you
and so I was like I made these cheesy
little business cards on Vista Print and
I was like I'm just going to start
giving them to all the female comedians
that come in to be like can I be assist
SAR Silverman would come in she did Soul
cycle yeah um who else did I mean
everybody did yeah it I got annoyed I I
got annoyed by it I got annoyed that
like it was like I don't know I felt
like a lot of publicists a lot of
publicists yeah I felt like a lot of
publicists like listening to like
inspiring I don't know it just felt and
there's no soul in the soul cycle no and
then also they would I don't do this
thing where exercise instructors get to
just be mean to you and like publicly
humiliate you I do that on my own I had
a mic pack thrown at my head when I was
in the back like cleaning like the
headset somebody came in and they had
like you know song skipped or whatever
and and this somebody threw a mic pack
and I had to like Dodge it yeah that's a
no it's a no there's um uh someone I
know
she her like when you do spin whatever
there's your shoe locks into the pedal
like and there's like a screw that pops
up and her foot popped out and it's
fileted feted yeah yeah her entire Shin
feted the entire shin and I was like I'm
done yeah I was obviously looking for an
excuse I'm like well it's just not safe
I just can't get fileted uh let me tell
you if you came in late to the class and
the bikes are so squished together I had
to go in there and I would have to like
plug in like literally clip in
celebrities feets like when Madonna
would come her shoes would already be
clipped in then she just slide her shoes
in and I said f and you're like trying
to the nightmare it doesn't have to be
that dark somebody bit their tongue once
and it like class and there was blood
everywhere and because it's very viscous
so this guy comes out he's got a towel
full of blood and he's like I bit my
tongue during class and this is before
you had like PPE stop doing a Raymond
pill depression that's where Ray and I
met working at Soul cycle we we were the
two chubby kids working in the front
desk always hung over I was always in
like a catatonic stuper going in there I
don't blame you sorry no do not apiz am
i g to get through this I don't know do
not apologize and then we would is Pixie
going to yell at me Pixie sweet pixie
love pixie shout out to pixie it was
roor who scared me yeah they they just
all of them were very scary yeah well it
was wild to see that they had like these
psycho fans and stalkers dude don't even
get me started on the soul cycle
instructor Cults where like it was like
people would go there 45 minutes early
and they would try to hang out with them
I was like I don't this is this person
is not your friend Ben I love Benner he
was my guy he was my guy cuz he would
literally play like random I was kind of
in his goal I was I would be like when I
would see him on Instagram hanging out
with other people in the class I'd be
jealous like this is like high school
this is ridiculous we would also have to
sometimes like deal with the stalkers
like there were times where we had like
people's faces in the back and I'm like
okay for a lot of the female instructors
too uhhuh and then I used to wait on the
beckhams all the time and they were so
lovely and so kind but Victoria W day
just lowkey asked me she like so do do
you do this a lot and I was in the best
shape of my life I was like yeah I
actually spend twice a day and she's
like all right like I could tell she was
kind of like all right okay yep uhuh and
then I told her my first concert was a
Spice Girl and she didn't like that cuz
I think it aged her and I was like you
understand
interesting I have started getting the
um I've loved you since I was a kid and
I'm
like uhhuh okay it's like being shot
like you have been you have been shot
and I I should have I like I should have
inserted foot and mouth but yeah it's
bad when the celebrities come in they're
like do you do this exercise can't h a
Billionaire's feelings that's true
that's science that is true but I did
get to technically go to second base
with David Beckham because I was letting
somebody in late into the class and you
know the bikes are squished so he was on
the front row and I had to help somebody
clip in and I got up and I my tits were
right on his shoulder and he was so nice
about and he has not felt tits in a very
long time exactly and he was like don't
worry about it and kind of winked at me
and I came out of that room and I was
glowing I was like guys David Beckham is
feeling The Vibes yeah yeah I mean I've
Got dirt on everybody I behead I
remember one time it was closed for
Beyonce oh yeah she was lovely
yeah the best Charlie Saron the nicest
person on nicest nicest I remember
Carrie Mulligan would come and Michelle
Monahan like we had yeah yeah and now
when I see some of these people out in
about in the the world I'm like yeah I
remember you tapped it back you tapped
it back uhhuh uhhuh you were always late
you were 15 minutes late to class every
time so annoying yeah so if you're an
inspiring um actor or comedian go work
at a gym in La this this is like I don't
this is the kind of Gossip I'm like on
the edge of my seat Soul cycle gossip
I'll tell you off air who was worst uh
then we're going to wrap